Ladies and gentlemen, our program is about to begin.
The AACR Annual Meeting is the focal point of the cancer research
community, where attendees gather to share the latest advances in
cancer science and medicine. With the theme of Precision.
Partnership. Purpose. Advancing Cancer Science to Save
Lives Globally, the AACR Annual Meeting highlights the work
of the best minds in cancer research from around the world.
Welcome to San Diego.
Good morning, everyone.
Thank you very much for joining us today for this last plenary
on the last day of a truly outstanding meeting.
I think you all agree with me, it's been incredible.
So my name is Katie Rezvani. I'm Professor and
Director of the Cell Therapy Institute at MD Anderson
Cancer Center, and it's my distinct pleasure to
chair this morning's plenary session.
So this session, called
New Modalities Shaping the Future of Oncology,
really considers precision medicine through the
lens of different therapeutic modalities.
Precision medicine is no longer about matching a drug with a
target.
It's about selecting the right therapeutic platform for the
biology in front of us.
Across targeted radiation, antibody drug conjugates,
biologics, and cell therapies,
each modality brings a distinct way
of treating disease and targeting
cancer. This session brings these approaches
together not as separate advances, but as
complementary strategies that can
collectively broaden how we think about cancer treatment,
and also what precision medicine can achieve.
So without further ado, it's my distinct pleasure to
invite our first speaker to the podium.
Dr. Martin Pomper is Professor and Chair of Radiology at the
University of Texas Southwestern Medical Center, and
he's a pioneer in the development of new imaging and
therapeutic agents for cancer. Dr. Pomper. Thank you.
Okay. Well, thanks for the kind introduction.
Thanks to everybody for being here so early on the last day.
It's a real honor for me to be here today, and I'll talk about
theranostics, and perhaps some of you can consider
bringing these into your practices.
So, some disclosures.
So by way of outline, first I'll talk about precision imaging.
I'll talk about imaging and therapy, which is sort of the backbone of
theranostics,
emerging targets, and then I'll give a perspective at the end.
So when we think about precision medicine, we think of it as a
genetic phenomenon where a patient's genome or their
epigenome might determine what sort of precise,
exact therapy that they might be getting.
But to me, I look at the genetics somewhat as on-the-ground
intelligence about the patient, whereas with imaging, we
have spatial information. So now we can design
guided missiles to be able to take out various malignant
lesions very specifically, going after specific targets.
So one thing that we could do, with precision imaging, is that we can subtype
disease. So patients A and B have very
similar phenotypes. They both have high-risk prostate cancer.
I think it was Gleason 9 prostate cancer.
But with this precision imaging agent, we see that
patient A has localized disease. Patient
B already has disseminated disease.
So these two patients are going to have vastly different journeys with their
cancer. So we can subtype the disease.
They may even have different types of prostate cancer.
So that's what we can now do with precision
imaging.
So when we think about what imaging is for, we think about how it
decreases mortality by screening, decreases cost,
decreases length of an episode of care, but these are really
somewhat conventional ways to think about imaging.
But now, with precision imaging, we now have
proteogenomics, so we can find new targets for
imaging, for molecular imaging. There are new ways of generating
affinity probes to those targets.
Chemistry is a little bit simpler than it
was when I was in graduate school. Now they have
click chemistry. We don't have to be organic chemists to make
these things always. We have very highly relevant
genetic animal models of a human disease.
Very sensitive new devices like total body PET.
Everything we do is on our computers.
But probably the most important advance in not just
imaging, not just medicine, and seemingly in life these days,
is that all this work, and most of the work that we do now,
is able to be collated, annotated, analyzed, and utilized through
cloud computing,
and I'll mention a couple things about that toward the end.
So my former collaborator at Johns Hopkins, Bert Vogelstein,
had this paper out about now 10 years ago, where he said that
variation in cancer risk among tissues can be explained by the number of stem cell
divisions.
So a little bit complicated title, but if you pull out
the abstract, it says that, "Only a third of the variation in cancer risk
among tissues is attributable to environmental factors or inherited
predispositions. The majority is due to bad
luck."So we don't hear bad luck often in science papers.
But what I think that Bert means by this is that no matter
how much kale you eat, and no matter how much time you spend on the
elliptical, two-thirds of the time, cancer is
bad luck.
So his solution is to detect it as early as
possible, and he does that using circulating tumor DNA.
And to do it with circulating tumor DNA, you need about 50 million cells,
which is a number I'd like you to remember for a minute.
That's one way to detect cancer. We're going to do it
through imaging.
Now, when I was a junior faculty member, I was a
neuroradiologist. I was interested in
glutamatergic neurotransmission.
And in order to image glutamate in the brain, I
thought that if there were an enzyme
such as nalidase, that we could somehow
label with a positron-emitting affinity agent, that
we'd be able to map out where glutamate is happening in the brain,
and it would be something that would be important because glutamate's a
very important transmitter. And this particular paper that I just came
across just by chance, I saw they had very high affinity
inhibitors, but the inhibitors were very hydrophilic,
and they looked a lot like the natural substrate for the enzyme,
NaAG, and they weren't going to get across the blood-brain barrier.
So I put this project on a back burner as soon as I
saw this paper at the same time back in 1996.
This is a paper by Joe Coyle's group where he showed that
prostate-specific membrane antigen was the same as
that brain enzyme. So I immediately pivoted everything to
prostate cancer and said, "Forget about schizophrenia
and Alzheimer's disease, et cetera, and let's work on this.
No blood-brain barrier here." So we can develop small molecule
agents for prostate cancer. So at the time,
in the mid-'90s, there was an agent.
It was an antibody agent, for detecting
PSMA for prostate cancer. But it didn't work particularly
well. The images were not particularly visually appealing.
So we thought that a small molecule might have better
pharmacokinetics, and we can get clearer, crisper pictures of prostate cancer.
So after many years, we eventually developed this
compound labeled with fluorine-18, which is for positron emission
tomography,
and we're able to image very tiny lesions like this lesion in
the marrow.
Now, the idea here is to change the way that we manage
prostate cancer, potentially, if we're going to integrate imaging.
So Dr. Vogelstein needs about 50 million cells.
We need on the same order of cells. So if somebody
is at high risk for metastasis, you might
have the blood test first. If there's a hit, then we could come in and
use the somewhat more expensive imaging study.
We can see exactly where the lesion is.
We could call our friends like Phu Tran, who's a radiation oncologist.
He could do stereotactic radiation, and he could take out that lesion before the
patient even feels that they're ill.
So the point is to get the disease while it's just oligo
rather than polymetastatic.
So we kept working on these agents to image
prostate cancer targeting PSMA, and we learned
that we needed about a 20 Angstrom linker
between the affinity part, this urea, and the
chelator in order to get productive binding to PSMA.
So this way, we could start putting radiometals attached to our
affinity agents. So now, we can image, and then we can
potentially use molecular radiotherapeutics.
That's kind of what theranostics are, and this is what got us into
theranostics. We also showed that the small
molecules would be able to be internalized, just like the
antibodies could be. Internalization is a good quality for
a theranostic because then you get long residence times and long
exposures of the
particulate emissions to the tumor, which I'll talk about in a minute.
So theranostics can
be used at many different points during the patient's
journey. But we're going to focus over here on sort of
this image-based guidance, specifically radiodiagnosis,
radiotherapy.
So the theranostic agent really has three parts to it.
It's got the affinity agent, the substrate, what binds to your target.
It's got a linker, which is often a chelating agent for a radiometal,
which can either be a imaging or diagnostic or a therapeutic
nuclide. So for imaging or for therapy, that's what theranostics
is. I put the word target in red here because
the target is the most important thing.
Okay, so once you have the target,
chances are you're going to be able to figure out how to engage that target
productively. It may not take overnight, but
you'll be able to figure it out, particularly with new technologies, as I'll
discuss. You want that target, if it's biologically
important, all the better. You want its expression restricted to the
tumor. You want it in high concentrations in the tumor, high affinity
for your agent, suitable pharmacokinetics for the drug that
you're giving. These are essentially drugs.
You want long residence time and internalization to match the
pharmacokinetics between your physical
half-life on your radionuclide and your agent that you're
giving, and then, of course, you want limited off-target effects.
The bottom line is that these compounds are all synthesized and
optimized using the tools of medicinal chemistry just like anything
else with a few differences,
and that's why we're beginning to see a lot more medicinal chemists and
other chemists that are getting into the business.So these are
the radiotheranostics that are currently in clinical development.
This is just some of the theranostics for
prostate cancer, specifically for PSMA.
Now, there are many other targets
that can be used for prostate cancer, whether you want a
castration-resistant disease or potentially neuroendocrine
prostate cancer. So little by little, the more we learn about these
targets, the more we can do about the cancer.
So we, in imaging or in chemistry, rely very
heavily on you to find targets that
we can act upon.
So this just shows that there are other targets.
The two main targets right now that are being
approached are SSTR2 and PSMA, but
many others are coming along, carbonic anhydrase,
CD45, and others.
In terms of the preclinical world, there are hundreds, I
don't know, maybe
1,000 new targets that are being pursued, shown here in this very
nice recent article. And the nuclides are shown
and the affinity agents. So all these different things have to be optimized to
get this to work.
So just in the last few years, this slide, I couldn't have
shown this slide five years ago, but in the last few years,
industry, commercial entities have gotten very interested.
This is in the US and Canada, despite the fact that there are really only a
very few of these theranostics that have been approved, that have gone
through registration trials.
This is in Europe. In the Middle East, there's another set of companies.
In Australia and Asia. And this has really sparked interest
in the field, which is why even though I've been working in this area for 40
years and no one seemed to care about it, as soon as Novartis
got involved and it shows that these things work to a
certain extent, that's when everybody began to pay attention.
So really what we're talking about are beta emissions and alpha emissions.
Beta particles or electrons need a couple hundred decays,
single strand breaks.
Those are not as strong as alpha emitters.
Helium nuclei, these cause double strand breaks, very hard for the
cells to repair. So I think the future is sort of moving
a little bit more toward alpha particle emitters.
But the beta emitters are what are in widespread use now, and this slide's
already about maybe seven or eight years old,
but what this shows is the PSMA 617.
It's essentially a radiochemical debulking of tumor.
So you can take patients with PSAs close to 1,000 and reduce
them almost to nothing and wipe out just about all the tumor
visually, at least the PSMA positive tumor.
Tremendously good for quality of life as
well.
So one reason that you might think about bringing these into your practice is that
they're safe and effective. So you could see that the PSA
50 declines are
better than they are for cabazitaxel, and they tend to be much
milder in terms of the side effects.
So even though I'm a radiologist, I have patients that call and say, "How can I get
some of this? I don't want to take chemo." So it's
a very nice new agent in that regard.
So alpha emitters. So pivoting here, there are
kind of the two biggies are actinium and lead.
I'm going to advocate a little bit for astatine.
And astatine, also an alpha emitter, shorter physical half-life.
What I like about it is there's only one alpha decay, so you have
full control over where your
decay is going to be deposited. It's going to be deposited in the tumor.
For actinium, for example, there's a recoil
after the first decay, and you may
somehow lose track of where those other alpha decays are going to happen.
They may not happen in the tumor. Anyway, this is all
theoretical. But astatine is also nice.
It's a halogen. It can be incorporated into small molecules
without disrupting the pharmacokinetics too much.
So we could start thinking about intracellular targets.
We don't just have to be on the cell surface all the time.
So astatine is something that we've been focusing on, and I've been
working with Michael Ziolkowski, and after a
fair amount of optimization, we developed a compound that
binds PSMA labeled with astatine.
We interestingly have a chelator out here mainly for pharmacokinetic
purposes, not for actual radioactivity or
distributing the radioactivity.
There are a lot of nuances that I think are not
bad to mention when you're developing these kind of compounds.
For example, the idea of carrier or non-radiolabeled
material that binds the same receptor as
the radiolabeled material. You can modify
how much off-target effect that you get if you add
carrier or if you make material that has lower specific
radioactivity. You might get a little bit less uptake in the tumor, but you
get much, much less in the off-target sites.
So that's one way to keep these things safer.
Another thing about astatine is that you can actually image it directly.
So this is a SPECT scan, and we can see that directly.
We can use this for doing precision dosimetry if we really
want to. Right now,
everyone gets kind of the same dose.
It's easy to do, easy to work into the clinic.
But we may go toward precision dosimetry in the future.
So there's a lot of other targets. There's a whole list, and you could read
about the other targets. We had focused on
carbonic anhydrase IX using small
moleculeinhibitors. And you can see
the primary tumor here. You could see that there are lesions in
the upper mediastinum. We do have some
gastric uptake. I think that's an undesirable on-target
effect, so we still need to work on that a little bit
further. Another very common target is fibroblast
activation protein.
This is in the tumor microenvironment.
The advantage here is that FAP is present in almost all solid tumors,
so I think it's going to be great for imaging.
The first compound that we made a long time ago had very
high affinity, picomolar affinity.
However, we couldn't image anything with it.
It wouldn't image the tumors, and I believe it's because there was
a secreted version of FAP that was mopping
up our imaging agent. And we learned that when we
gave higher amounts of carrier, we show that we were
able to block the nonspecific binding in blood
and get more uptake in the tumor. So I'm showing this
mainly because there are lots of different things that you have to juggle in order
to keep them safe and in order to get adequate signal to
noise.
So just a couple of weeks ago, we took our
compound, different than this, and we
finally showed a very nice primary... Well, very nice.
A terrible primary tumor in this patient with pancreatic cancer
and several lesions in the liver. We changed the management, and this is our
very first research subject, because you couldn't see these
liver lesions on CT or on MR. So
that's what we can do now with precision imaging.
We hope to turn that into a
therapeutic.
So, a little perspective. Doors have been opened
with advances in many different areas, all at the
same time over the last five or six years to enable us to
get to where we are, but there's really a tremendous amount for us to do.
So this is the VISION trial, the registration trial for the PSMA
617, and even though this is life-prolonging
therapy if you add it to standard care, you don't
really prolong life that much. This is overall survival.
I think progression-free survival increase was about five months.
So the Kaplan-Meier curves to me, despite the fact that these
patients were terribly ill, still too close
together,
and especially if you take a look at what this does to the cancer
itself. So what this tells me is that we're leaving
maybe one or two clones behind, and then it comes back, and
unfortunately, the Kaplan-Meier curves are close together.
So now,
many groups around the world are trying to pry those Kaplan-Meier curves
apart. So for example, I like this very
interesting study
called LUNAR, where they do a neoadjuvant debulking
with the molecular radiotherapy, and then they do metastasis-directed
stereotactic radiation. And now they find that they get
a little bit more progression-free survival that way.
So incrementally, I think that we're going to leverage these
theranostics along with other entities so that we can really
be able to manage these patients. So what are the challenges in the
field? Right now, we need more people to do it.
It's generally led by nuclear medicine physicians.
We need more personnel. That's just the delivery of the
agents. We need more people to synthesize the compounds, to dig
up the radioisotopes. There's a huge
supply chain.
We're not quite sure how to dose patients now.
Right now, as I mentioned,
everybody gets kind of the same dose.
We need to make that more precise. The tumors are notorious
heterogeneous. There's lineage plasticity, so these things will
adapt to androgen receptor
inhibitors. There's mutations that occur, so they're very
heterogeneous, both between patients, within the patient, within the tumor.
All these things have to be overcome.
Supply chain is a little bit of a challenge. Who gets these things?
They're very expensive. Do you have to be a millionaire to get them, or
can anyone get them who could benefit from them?
And then the uncertainty of federal funding is important because
just about all the discoveries in all of these
different targets, and frankly, all the supporting
biology tends to happen in academic labs.
So all that work that we did with PSMA was funded by the
NIH, and now that's a little bit uncertain.
So I'll end by just talking about a few things that I think are going to be
important going forward.
AI, of course. So AI now can be
used for
discovering new targets, the whole pipeline for lead
discovery, optimization, et cetera.
My colleague Yong Du has built a human scanner
specifically for interrogating the distribution of alpha particle
emitters in the body so we can do precision dosimetry.
We could see what the pharmacokinetics look like.
He uses AI-based algorithms to do his imaging.
Imaging is not just
nice pictures, imaging is data.
But I do want to say one thing, one caution about the magic
of artificial intelligence is that you can teach a
convolutional neural network on a million bone scans,
and it'll be able to interpret that bone scan.
But in this real-life situation, where one of the radiation oncologists asked us,
"Should we go ahead and irradiate this thing here?
You said it was a possible metastasis."
So we suggested,
before it was approved by the FDA, that you use one of our imaging
agents, and we showed that by using the imaging agent that there was actually more
cancer in that patient than met the eye.So you could
see that we're still a little bit ahead of the machines, at
least just for a few years. And now we're training the machines on
these images so that we can get even closer
to where we need to be.
So for example, now we can automatically, this is a fully automated pipeline
where we could automatically detect and localize the lesions.
We can segment the lesions, extract features from them, combine
that information with the protected health information.
We can hopefully start providing very specific
recommendations to patients. But overall, the idea of bringing
AI into this workflow is that we want to be able to combine the power
of AI and the sensitivity and specificity of
molecular imaging so that we can get as close to human
biochemistry non-invasively as possible.
Number two is we have a rational comb-- I think there's a lot of
possibilities for rational combinations.
I personally tend to like those that have an immunological
component. This was a new trial that came out, PRINCE,
and this is where they do tumor debulking, then they give the checkpoint inhibitor.
The PSA 50 was 76%, the PSA 90 was
about 50%. But I think that
was really mainly due to the theranostic.
And frankly, we have to do this very gingerly
because the checkpoint inhibitors do have some side effects here.
But the reason I like
combining this with some sort of an immunological component is that we really
have to get every last clone if we're going to have cures.
And a couple of years back, we developed
a reporter, actually a PSMA reporter gene that we knocked into
CAR T cells, and we could actually follow the CAR T cells around,
and this mouse has leukemia,
and you could see how after a couple of weeks, those CAR T
cells, they do not let go of the tumor.
So when you really see that, it really made an impression on me.
And you can also see
axillary lymph nodes in the animal. So we want to get every clone.
I think we need immunology to do that.
Also, we're seeing more high throughput experimentation being applied to
radiopharmaceuticals and developing new PET agents using
spheroids and organoids instead of animals.
These are more NIH-compatible things to work with
nowadays.
We're also
seeing new affinity agents. There are VHHs, peptides,
macrocyclic peptides, small molecules.
Antibodies are still out there in play.
Mostly small molecules. I tend to prefer those myself.
They tend to have better tumor penetration if you want to start going for
other than liquid tumors. So the small molecules are
helpful. A lot of organic chemists are now getting into the
business where they're
starting to apply late-stage introduction of
fluorine-19,
cold fluorine. They're trying to adapt that to fluorine-18
syntheses. Fluorine-18 has a two-hour physical half-life, so you've got to be
very quick with your syntheses. But lots of new applications
there.
I just saw this paper yesterday, and I thought I would mention it.
Laura Wood's group at Johns Hopkins
is doing-- They have a 3D
multi-omic approach to find
new mechanisms of tumor resistance.
So the more biology, and that's why I see a lot of my friends here from the
radiology chemistry world, they want to learn about biology
so that they could leverage some of these new
pathways so that they can be able to design ways
of managing patients with cancer.
So I'll end by saying that I think that the field of theranostics right
now,
it sort of follows Amara's law. So
what this law says is that the shape of things to
come is really in an S. So as we saw with
personal computers, with cell phones, in the early
days, we might have thought that this was hype, where we were
overestimating, our expectations were too high.
Eventually, our expectations were met, and
our expectations have been exceeded.
Think about cell phones and communications.
I'm hoping that that's where we are now with theranostics.
We're somewhere around here, and that we will also exceed expectations so
that we could manage patients with cancer with this new therapy, and it'll
come in alongside surgery, radiation, chemotherapy, and
immunotherapy, and you'll give it consideration for your patients
going forward. And with that, I want to thank my-- Well, this was my
group at Johns Hopkins. I just moved a couple of years ago to UT
Southwestern.
And I guess this is not exactly the best forum for
questions, but I'm very easy to reach if you ever need to reach
me. Thank you very much.
What a fantastic presentation. Thank you so much, Dr. Palomba.
I certainly have questions, and I'm going to come and catch up with you afterwards.
Really interesting.
So our second speaker
is Dr. Raffaele Colombo, who's director of medicinal chemistry at
Zymeworks, a biotech company based in
Vancouver, Canada. And the title of
his presentation is,
"The Revolution of Antibody Drug Conjugates From Early
Concept to Next Generation Cancer Therapy."
Dr. Colombo. Thank you.
Thank you, Cathy, and thank you ECR for having me.
These are my disclosure. Let's start with some numbers.
So we have now more than 550 ADC that
enter clinical development, 14 approved by
FDA, five approved by NMPA in China,
more than 300 in clinical development.
But it's not always been easy, we have almost 200
that has been discontinued. And the landscape has really
changed over time. In the '90s, calicheamycin
started to work. In the 2000, mitansinoid and
auristatin.
A focus on PBD, but in the recent year there has been an
explosion of Top1, so camptothecin ADC, with more
than 200 that are now in clinical development with this class
of drugs.
And our understanding of ADC has also changed, and these are some
publication that we had with collaborators and
friends.
Let's start with understanding the fate of ADC because this is quite important to
understand how we develop next generation ADC.
After dosing, ADC distributes,
and distributes mainly in normal tissue and normal cell
with less than 1% usually reaching the tumor cell.
And how do we know it?
We have direct imaging with radiolabeled ADC, and we just saw a beautiful
presentation on radiolabeled drugs, as well
as and mainly with radiolabeled antibody.
And this is an example of trastuzumab with zirconium with
less than 1% reaching tumor type.
ADC can also has instability, and based on the chemistry, we can
have linker drugs that are perfectly stable,
medium stability, and even that release the drug very quickly with
half-life less than one day or less than two days.
And we can measure this in the clinic, but also we understand
the chemistry behind these drugs.
And all these mechanism are going to release payload in
circulation, and we can measure payload PK.
And you can see here with the ADC PK and the payload PK,
where the payload is continually released.
So ADC are an effective and important class of drugs,
but they don't really spare normal cell, as you can see from this graph
here.
So if ADC is just a magic bullet, so it goes
only into the tumor, then we want the payload as potent as possible, the
linker as stable as possible, and the antibody with the high
affinity as possible. But we just saw the disposition,
so we want the payload to be a drug-like, because it's going to be released
somewhere, with adequate potency and not the most
potent. The linker maybe doesn't need to be overly stabilized,
because if you overly stabilize, may end up into normal tissue more.
And the antibody should optimize for tumor penetration
and payload delivery, and not just for affinity.
Looking at potency, the potency of the payload really
correlates with the clinical dose of ADC.
And you can see here camptothecin reaching higher clinical dose than
mitansinoid, auristatin, with PBD reaching very
low clinical dose. And why the dose is important?
First, we want to dose ADC high enough to overcome
target expression, what is called antigen sync.
And if you can see here, non-linear PK, if we dose
trastuzumab or trastuzumab-based ADC, T-DM1 or T-DXd,
below a certain dose, the one in red, with a linear
PK and no target-mediated clearance
when we dose the ADC high enough, in this case, the one in green.
And higher ADC dose is also expected to favor
tumor penetration. In this study, an antibody conjugated with
a dye, when we inject a lower dose, then it get
blocked in the tumor barrier. But if we inject a higher dose, in this
case, with a naked antibody at a higher dose, you can see how it really
penetrate well into tumor in patients.
And so based on this principle, we design, for example,
our ZW291 ADC, which is a folate alpha
conjugated with a Top1.
The payload, we made more than 100 payload, and we chose
one that was not the most potent, you can see in the middle
here, but was really designed for ADC properties.
And you can see the potency of our payload compared to other
payload that are used in the clinic for different type of ADC.
That is not one of the most potent, but it's one of with the moderate
potency.
And the antibody, we really designed the antibody for
internalization and deeper spheroid penetration.
In this case, our antibody in blue compared to mirvetuximab,
which is the antibody used in Mirve, an approved drug in the folate
space. And you can see very well how much high
internalization and much deeper penetration in a spheroid
model.
And Dr. Larusso presented yesterday the phase one, and this
really translate in benefit for patient with more than
50% overall response rate in phase one, in dose
escalation. And maybe I pointed out here, in the
dose selected for expansion,
61% overall response rate. And the toxicity
was very manageable, with toxicity mainly
hematological and GI that is typical of Top1
ADC.
Now let's go to how we can do better.
This is the current status. How can we go into the next
generation of ADC?And we need to improve efficacy, we need
to improve safety, and overcome resistance.
And based on three themes, we are working on novel
targets, novel payloads, novel linkers, some
outside of the box approaches. But really, I want to conclude my talk later
on to really understand disposition and PK in order
to design better drugs.
Let's start with resistance. Resistance to ADC can come from the target,
it can come from the payload, or it can come from the linker.
While for the linker, there is no evidence of clinical resistance to the
linker, only preclinical work, so I'm going to focus on the
target and the payload.
Starting with the target, taking trastuzumab deruxtecan,
one of the most successful ADC, is a HER2 targeting with a
Top1 payload. In this study from MSK, they look at the
target downregulation compared to pre-T-DXd and
post-T-DXd with almost 50%
downregulation on the target.
And on the right, in another study, they look at
pre-T-DXd and post-T-DXd for target mutation, in this case, mutation
of HER2, and increase, but it's still a small
percent, so it's not one of the main mechanisms of resistance.
And resistance to the target doesn't always emerge.
Taking Destiny Destinia-HER2, for example, almost 100% of patients have
seen trastuzumab. Almost 100% has seen
TDM-1, and then it's randomized to T-DXd and standard of care.
Same antibody, trastuzumab, trastuzumab emtansine, and
then again, trastuzumab deruxtecan.
And the benefit is evident, 70% overall response
rate after second line
treating with the same antibody and almost 40 months
overall survival.
But if you have resistance to the target, well, you can change the target
or you can work on bispecific ADC.
Let's go to the target.
Twelve targets
are across ADC that have been approved and are shown here in
green. More than 80 targets are actually in clinical
development, and some of these are common between the approved and the
one in development. And almost 100 targets have been
discontinued. And again, some of them are in common.
And some of these targets that are discontinued maybe were discontinued
because the biology of the payload didn't really match with the
target and maybe revisit with a better payload in the future.
And on the right, you see the ones that are popular right now.
In the past two years, cadherin 17, claudin 18.2,
folate, ROR1, and so on. These are the targets that
have been popular in the past two years.
And the idea is that in the future, we could have different
ADCs that are approved for different targets, and we can really personalize
based on looking at what targets are overexpressed in the
patient and choose the right target, because a patient with a
low or no target expression may benefit
from an ADC, but might benefit more from another
ADC with a better target, or we can see in a bit with a better
payload.
Bispecific ADC are rising, more than 80 abstracts at this
annual meeting, and the idea you can target a target A or a
target B, so increase your patient population
or target
A and target B to be more selective.
We have more than 40 bispecific ADC in the clinic,
and these are rising. And I know the table is impossible to read, but
focus on the figure. Majority of them are anchoring
to targets that are well-known, EGFR, c-Met,
HER3, B7H3, but some of the new targets are also
emerging, shown here. And
despite all this bispecific ADC in the clinic, we have
data only for EGFR by HER3 so far,
and the most advanced one is a brand,
has a high affinity for EGFR, low affinity for HER3,
a Top1 payload, and a cleavable linker.
And you can see I show efficacy in many tumor
types and many indications.
Toxicity profile is a classic potent
Top1 inhibitor with significant hematological toxicity,
GI, and other toxicity, maybe some of them also related to
the target, including stomatitis and rash.
Let's go to the payload, one of my favorite topics.
The elephant in the room is that we cannot treat
a patient with the same ADC and another ADC with the same payload
class. You see on the left, looking at PFS of one ADC
after one other ADC, and on the right, Time to Next
Treatment of one ADC and another ADC with the same payload class.
Regarding resistance to the payload can come from target
mutation of the drug or, since these are still
chemotherapy, from
overexpression of efflux pumps.
Looking at
resistance to the target, in this case, Top1 mutation.
In this study from MGH on the left,
13% of Top1 mutation was found in patients treated with
ADC compared to patients treated with chemo that is not
an ADC.
In this study presented this week from MD Anderson,
3.4% of patients treated with Top1 ADC.
And in this analysis of Destiny 1.0, 2.0, and 3.0,
between 3% and 5.5% across different
responders.
But as I mentioned, efflux pumpAre emerging
and are starting to show that correlation with increase of
efflux pump and reduce benefit. In the
study of the left, real-world of a large number of
patients with breast cancer, reduced overall survival with
overexpression of ABCC1. In destiny colorectal
two,
reduced PFS with overexpression of Pgp.
And in the analysis of destiny breast one or two or three, they show no
correlation with expression of the pump, but they didn't
mention durational response or survival
endpoints, which probably correlates with a reduced
benefit with increased efflux pumps.
And if you are resistant to a payload, then, of course, you can change payload
or you can work on dual payload, trying to use the other payload to
overcome resistance to the first payload.
Develop ADC and the new payload is hard.
We are seeing recent discontinuation across many classes,
including ISAC, degrader, BCL-2,
MTI, Topo 2, DNA-damaging agent, and
KSP inhibitors.
But some new payload are starting to enter in the
clinic, including actinocidin,
PI3K and PIKK with two ADC,
dual payload which I'm going to focus a little bit, and novel payload
classes that are not in the clinic yet but are emerging and
everybody's trying to focus on what's next
in term of payloads.
Dual payload, we have six in the clinic right now,
and as you can see, all of them are using a Topo 1 combined
with something else, and something else is STING, an ATR,
triptolide or MME. But more and
more are going to enter the clinic this year and next year.
And at this meeting, 37 abstract on dual payload ADC have
been presented.
For emerging payload, I focus on the one that had been presented
at this meeting. And as you can see, degraders are
emerging.
RAS,
there's been a lot of interest in RAS as a small molecule, especially
with the recent news, but we have been using RAS as a payload
for ADC that hopefully is going to enter the clinic soon.
And other class including translation inhibitor,
PI3K, ATR and so on.
Everybody saw Revolution Medicine data, so nothing too
new here.
Great and meaningful benefit for patient,
especially with the recent news on the randomized trial with 30 months
median overall survival. But toxicity is still an issue,
including rash, GI toxicity, and dose interruption,
reduction, and discontinuation with this dose proportionality.
So the idea with an ADC is that we can improve over a
small molecule inhibitor of RAS, really
focusing on what DC is good of, sustained tumor
exposure. And if you can sustain tumor exposure, when we
can improve efficacy,
reduce side effect,
and enable combination that maybe are not manageable
for combining a pan-RAS small molecule or a
specific with certain other agents.
We made more than 170 new pan-RAS
inhibitors. And again, similar to our Topo
experience, we focus on one that was not the most
potent but was designed for ADC.
And as you can see here,
it show very good efficacy in CDX models, as low as
one mg per kg single injection, very good PK and
linear PK,
great bystander activity, and more importantly, tolerability
in non-human primate at MTD that is higher than
120 because we didn't go higher with no body weight
loss, no GI data toxicity, and more importantly, no skin
toxicity, which we know is an issue for the class as a small molecule.
And we have multiple programs that we are moving forward.
And this is probably one of important
experiment to show how an ADC can really differentiate from a
small molecule. If you look at an ADC, it
sustain
the inhibition of RAS for an extended period of time, we are talking about
14 days after single dose, with a good differentiation from normal
tissue, whereas a small molecule, you do
have inhibition of RAS, in this case measured as USP6
reduction, but same reduction in the tumor as
in normal tissue, skin, liver, and colon that we measure.
So overall, the idea is that we think an ADC can really
transform how we use even RAS for treating
patients.
Now the linkers. There's a lot of interest from ADCs based on what's called
the linkerlogy.
And the question that we need to ask is,
we have a substantial change or we have
incremental benefit? Or are we making worse, changing the
linker when we make a linker that is not better than what we have right now?
Regarding stability,
stability of the linker impact the site, the rate,
and how the payload is released. And we have a paper that was accepted
yesterday on Annals of Oncology, so I'm going to refer you to that.
Hydrophobicity is a problem for the payload, so
increasing hydrophilicity using masking technology
is really emerging for certain class of payload.
Different cleavable unitsChanging from
broad cathepsin to selective cathepsin, or changing completely the
enzyme, including glycosidases, legumain, and others.
And also some creative approach where you need two events
in order to completely cleave your payload.
In this case, for example, glucuronidase first, and after you cleave the
first
cleavable linker, then the second event can happen and releasing
the payload.
I'm going to move to some of the outside-of-the-box approaches, and these
are still ADC related
but quite interesting. One that is very interesting is
pre-targeting. So the idea here is that you have two
different timing of dosing. On the
left, you are dosing, for example, an ADC with a
linker that cannot be cleaved without a chemical, a
small molecule that can cleave the linker.
Work done by Tagworks, and one is in the clinic.
So the idea is that you have a pre-targeting, and then after a
certain time, the small molecule can cleave the linker and release the payload.
And another example led by Schaske, an antibody
fragment or an antibody with a tag
can bind to the tumor, and then the payload with a different tag is
injected, which when can find the first antibody can
release the payload.
Post-targeting, in this case, a completely different approach.
You are injecting your ADC with an antibody that bind the payload, and
the idea is that the second antibody can bind the payload
from systemic circulation. As I mentioned at the beginning of my talk, there
is a systemic circulation of the payload, and the second
antibody can
sequest the payload and reduce some of the toxicities that are
payload related. And finally, you can change
completely the moieties, including small molecules that have
antibody, peptide, antibody fragment,
aptamers, and nanoparticle. So quite interesting and a lot of
these are entering the clinic or already in the
clinic with different moieties.
And last part of my talk, I want to focus on
understanding disposition and PK.
This is a topic that I really like,
and it's very hard to find what's
best for ADC because a very complex molecule.
Let's start with T-DXd. As I mentioned, one of our most successful
ADC, HER2, DXd payload, DARate.
Stability of the linker is moderate.
If you put in an in vitro assay, deconjugate 50%
in seven days.
Looking at PK,
you have your ADC PK in gray with area
and your payload PK in blue. Half-life of almost six
days. With a payload half-life, since it keep generating and it
keep clear, which mirror your ADC PK.
And T-DXd show higher efficacy and higher
overall survival and PFS in patient with HER2 high.
Makes sense. It's an antibody to target HER2.
So in different study, you see how HER2 high and
higher overall response rate, which translate in PFS and
OS compared to HER2 low. But it works also in
HER2 low and HER2 zero, and this is due to
some of the bystander activity of the payload as well as sustained
concentration of the payload, which is above pharmacological
active level for a sustained period of time.
Completely different story for sacituzumab govitecan.
ADC approved,
targeting Trop-2, SEn-30A payload, DARate.
In this case, the linker is very unstable, and you can see here
how separate quite well between the total antibody
and the ADC. The payload again mirror the PK of the
ADC. Half-life is very short, less than a day.
And for this ADC, there is no correlation between Trop-2
and the responses in any of the trial that has been tested,
meaning that majority of efficacy comes actually from the
payload and not directly from target
delivery through an ADC effect.
This is amivadotine, another HER2, in this case, not
trastuzumab. Half-life of this ADC is quite interesting
because it's one of the case where the ADC half-life is
actually shorter than your payload half-life itself.
Thirty-one hours for ADC, 60 hours linker.
In this case, a moderate stable linker with an MMA payload,
DAR4. And again, no correlation between
efficacy and target expression. We saw good correlation
for trastuzumab deruxtecan, but for this ADC, there is no
correlation in breast cancer and no correlation in urothelial
cancer.
And finally, isabrin.
We just look at before great efficacy in many different tumor
types.
This ADC has a very stable linker. So the ADC
half-life is not driven by stability, it's driven
by the fact that the format, the bispecific format,
cause a very high clearance, and so the ADC half-life in
less than one day.
And this ADC, which is EGFR with high affinity, HER3
with low affinity, does not have any correlation in
responses with EGFR expression, HER3
expression, and also co-expression of
EGFR and HER3.
So ADC PK is also
very underappreciated, and I just show you how
successful ADC can really have a diverse PK
profile, having something that isModerate
stability with long half-life and approved as well
as very short half-life and still working quite well or
moderate or also again short, but the linker is very stable.
So the design of the ADC can
vary based on
your
linker that you use, your antibody that you use, or the design that you're
using for ADC.
And based on this, there is a delicate balance
between all these properties. So if you
have an ADC that has a very long half-life and the linker is very stable,
well, it behaves more as a conjugated drug.
Your ADC really matters where it goes, especially if it
has a known bystander payload, because after the payload is released,
if you cannot enter another cell, then everything is mediated by
your ADC.
If ADC has a very short half-life or the linker is very
unstable,
then it may behave more as a free drug.
And we see how efficacy sometimes does not correlate with target
expression, and the toxicity profile often
resemble the payload itself.
A majority of ADC, since ADC is quite complicated, they have a
partially stable and so is a complex mixture and evolving mixture of
all these properties, which is hard to design
for next generation ADC.
Takeaways. ADC are very important and effective
drugs, but as I just show, are very complex.
Next generation ADC will be multidimensional.
Novel target, including multi targets.
Novel payload, including multi payloads.
But we need to optimize payloads for ADC.
So often we take off-the-shelf payload, but we
need to work on payload that are designed for ADC.
I didn't have time to go too much into biomarker, but yesterday and two
days ago, both Sarat and Barbara Pistilli, they had
beautiful session on biomarkers, so please watch those if you haven't
watched it. Novel linkers. We really need to aim
for truly tumor-specific linkers, and this can be
game-changing. Right now, we have linker that can be cleaved as
well, causing what we've seen, a different
disposition and different profile.
If you can aim for truly tumor-specific linker, this can be game changing.
But all of this, we need a deeper understanding of the
pharmacokinetic and pharmacodynamic of ADC.
I want to thank the team as well as the leadership
and Pat Lo Russo for her friendship and all her
help. Thank you.
Thank you very much. Really, truly outstanding
presentation. A fantastic overview of the field and the
innovation. So thank you for that.
So our next speaker is Dr. Angela Coxon.
She's vice president of research and development at Amgen.
The title of her presentation is "From Molecular Design
to Therapeutic Impact: Protein Engineering Driving
T-Cell Engager Innovation." Thank you very much, Angela.
Good morning,
everyone. I'd like to thank the organizers for giving me the
opportunity to speak this morning, and I'd like to thank all of you for
making it to the last morning of AACR.
It's been quite an amazing meeting here in sunny San
Diego.
What I'm going to do today, I'm going to tell you about some really exciting
progress that we've made in the field of T-cell engagers.
These are my disclosures.
So what I'll do over the next 25 minutes or so is walk you through the
mechanism of action of T-cell engagers.
I'll tell you what we've learnt in the clinic from some of these programs.
I'll tell you about the barriers to expanding T-cell engagers
into additional solid tumors, and some of the protein
engineering strategies that we can take to try to mitigate
these challenges and bring forward T-cell engagers into
additional indications.
Sorry, I keep going the wrong way.
These are the four programs that I'll be telling you about this morning.
The prototype for T-cell engagers was really blinatumomab.
It was the first bispecific T-cell engager to be approved.
It targets CD19, and it's approved in acute lymphoblastic
leukemia.
By making some protein engineering changes, we could extend the
half-life, and talatinib is a molecule that targets
DLL3 and has been approved for small cell lung
cancer.
To try to bring molecules into other settings,
we've used an avidity-based approach.
We call that two plus one binding, and the molecule I'll highlight for
you is now called zalyutamig, and it's being
used to treat patients with prostate cancer.
And finally, I'll tell you about an exciting novel approach that
we refer to as dual targeting, where we use two
receptors to increase the therapeutic window and
move into additional indications.
So unfortunately, cancer remains the second leading
cause of death worldwide.We've been making some
great progress in the field over the past several decades,
much of which you've heard about from my co-presenters today
and throughout this meeting.
The graph that you're looking at on the right-hand side
shows the five-year survival percentage,
and in some indications, we've made tremendous progress.
The indications at the top of the slide, like melanoma,
prostate cancer, and breast, we're now in the 90%
range, which is truly remarkable.
But some of the indications at the bottom of the slide, we haven't been able
to make so much progress yet.
Immunotherapy has really been a revolution in the field.
And since the first wave of immunotherapy, the checkpoint
inhibitors were approved way back in 2011 and
2014. They've had a large impact on some of
these indications.
But still, it remains true that most patients don't derive
benefit from immunotherapy.
And so that's where T-cell engagers step up.
A T-cell engager is a targeted form of immunotherapy.
And the way it works is they're usually bispecific antibodies.
They have two arms. One arm binds to CD3 on a
T-cell, and the other arm binds to a
tumor-selective antigen.
By bringing the T-cell into close proximity with the tumor cell,
it results in the very specific and potent cell killing
of the tumor cells.
The T-cells become activated, and they go on to proliferate
and kill more tumor cells.
We found this to be one of the most potent mechanisms of cell
killing that we've looked at.
So as I mentioned, blinatumomab was the first T-cell
engager to be approved.
In this case, the structure of the molecule is shown on the left-hand side of the
slide, and it binds to CD19, which is
expressed on malignant B-cells.
The sections on the right-hand side of the slide come from a lymphoma
patient that was treated with blinatumomab.
And what you're looking at in the top two panels are bone marrow
sections that have been stained for either
malignant B-cells or T-cells.
After just 15 days of treatment, you can see that
most of the tumor cells have been eradicated and the
T-cells have expanded, very much in line with the
mechanism I just described.
And in the lower panel, you're looking at liver
biopsies from, again, a patient treated with blincyto.
In this case, the patient was treated for three weeks, but you
can see that the B-cells have been almost entirely
eradicated from the liver.
So I think this study really highlights the power of
T-cell engagers.
This was a clinical study that was run in acute lymphoblastic
leukemia,
and what the investigators did after the patients had been
treated with chemotherapy, they randomized them into two
treatment arms.
These patients were MRD negative at the time,
minimal residual disease negative.
There is no detectable disease.
And then they followed these patients for over five
years.
And you can see that the patients that received blinatumomab
plus chemotherapy do significantly better than
the patients that just received chemotherapy alone.
I should say that these patients only received four cycles of
treatment, and so it really shows the power of
T-cell engagers in developing a
safe and durable
response.
So I think these are really exciting data, and I hope we can go on
to see other data like this in other indications.
So since the approval of blinatumomab in 2014,
nine other T-cell engagers have been approved by the FDA,
and they're listed on this slide here.
You can see the molecule names, the target that they go after, the
format, and the approved indication.
The vast majority of these T-cell engagers have been approved in
hematologic malignancies.
Only two of them have been approved in the solid tumor setting,
and that is kimmtrak, which targets GP100
and was approved in uveal melanoma,
and more recently, talatrimab or imdeltrac, which
targets DLL3 and was approved in second line
small cell lung cancer.
For the rest of my presentation, I'll tell you about some of the challenges around
getting T-cell engagers approved in solid tumors and some of the
approaches we think we can take to try to overcome those
obstacles.
So what are the key challenges for developing these
molecules in solid tumors?
Well, as you heard from Dr. Pomper, one of the most important
aspects is the choice of target.
And what we've learned with T-cell engagers is they're incredibly
potent.
So any normal tissue expression results in
off-tumor activity, which can lead to toxicity
and safety issues. And so the selection of the target
is really
paramount.Target
heterogeneity is also an issue. You obviously want your target to
be expressed on as many cells as possible within the tumor, so
that you result in durable responses and
resistance cannot develop.
Another significant challenge for solid tumors is what we refer
to as the immunosuppressive tumor microenvironment.
What this means is that other cells within the
tumor microenvironment can prevent the T cells from working,
such as myeloid cells or other T cells.
And so we need approaches to try to mitigate the
immunosuppressive environment.
And finally, you obviously want your therapeutic to get into the tumor and
penetrate well, otherwise it's not going to work.
And so biodistribution is a key factor.
So we now need very specific and engineered molecules to try
to address some of those challenges, and I've listed some of them on
this slide.
We've been working on half-life extended formats so that we
can deliver intermittent dosing, which is much more convenient for the
patients.
Blinatumomab, when it was first developed, was
administered by continuous IV infusion.
And although it works well, we would like to have therapies that we could
deliver every week or every other week, so it's much more
convenient for the patient. We've been
working on approaches to mitigate the tumor microenvironment.
Those are approaches that we can use for T cell co-stimulation
or combination approaches, and I'll give you a couple of examples
of that later in my presentation.
Finally, we believe that avidity based or dual targeting
approaches is going to help us drive selectivity for tumors
and increase the therapeutic window.
So first let me tell you the story of Talatamab.
Talatamab is a T cell engager that targets DLL3.
And DLL3 has the ideal expression profile for
a T cell engager.
You can see on the left-hand side of the slide, the red dots
here, they represent patient samples, and they're all
patient samples from small cell lung cancer.
And what you're looking at is RNA expression data.
And so most patient samples express
DLL3.
It's between 80% and 90%.
But importantly, it's the blue squares that you have to pay
attention to. And the blue squares represent the normal
tissue expression across a panel of tissues.
And you can see there's very little expression of
DLL3 in normal tissues.
And we went on to do a lot of work to show that actually,
even that small amount of expression of DLL3 is
not expressed on the cell surface.
It's actually expressed in the Golgi, and so it's not accessible to a
T cell engager.
And so given this profile,
we designed the molecule on the right-hand side of the slide that's now known as
Talatamab.
It has potent binding to CD3 and very potent
binding to DLL3. Those are the two arms I talked about
earlier. And importantly, we've added a silent FC
domain to give us the extended half-life to allow us
intermittent dosing in the clinic.
This molecule has very potent activity on cells,
and some of that data is shown in the next slide.
On the right-hand side, you could see the cytotoxicity assay and a
cell-based assay. And in the top panel, you see the
activity in cells that express DLL3.
And very importantly, you see no activity when the
cells do not express DLL3.
On the left-hand side, you can see very potent T cell activation
and cytokine production, very much in line with that mechanism that
I described for a T cell engager.
Talatamab also has very compelling activity in
preclinical models.
In this primary small cell lung cancer model, weekly dosing of
Talatamab almost completely eradicated the tumors.
And on the right-hand side, we're looking at a liver metastasis model.
Again, treatment with Talatamab.
You can see in the liver sections below, there are almost no
metastases in this model.
And so together, these data and others
gave us the conviction that we should move Talatamab into clinical
testing.
And these data were published towards the end of last year.
This is the DELPHI-304,
Phase 3 study that led to the approval of Talatamab in
extensive stage second line small cell lung cancer.
The overall survival is shown for Talatamab in
turquoise. The median OS was 13.6
months, and the standard of care chemotherapy was
8.3 months.
So significant activity as monotherapy for Talatamab,
and really wonderful news that it's approved for patients with small cell lung
cancer.
Of course, following the framework of blinatumomab, we want
to move Talatamab into the frontline setting of small cell lung
cancer.And these data were recently published
where we've combined taladimab now with an anti
PD-L1 antibody.
We had fairly compelling preclinical data that treatment with
taladimab upregulated
PD-L1. And so there was strong scientific rationale for doing
this combination in the clinic.
This is now in the frontline setting.
This is a Phase 1b trial. And now you can see
it in red is treatment with atezolizumab.
Treatment in green is taladimab with durvalumab.
And finally, the blue line represents treatment with either of these
anti PD-L1 therapies.
And now the median OS in the frontline setting is up to
25.3 months.
And importantly, these patients had a very manageable
safety profile.
And so these data have given us conviction to move taladimab
in combination with an anti PD-L1 therapy into Phase
III clinical trials.
Very impressive clinical data.
But that's not all from the combination point of view.
As you heard about from my colleagues earlier today, we think combination
strategies are going to allow us to treat more patients and
have more durable responses. And I'm showing two
examples here. One is from an antibody drug conjugate that we just
heard about. The target here is B7H3.
And when we've combined taladimab with the antibody drug conjugate,
we see very compelling preclinical activity.
And we believe that targeting these orthogonal mechanisms will
lead to improved outcomes.
On the left-hand side, you're looking at combination with an IL-2
mutine.
This molecule, we believe, will overcome some of those
immunosuppressive
properties of solid tumors that we talked about.
And I'm pleased to say that both of these clinical studies are ongoing
at the moment in Phase 1.
So I've shown you very encouraging data
from taladimab, which targets DLL3 and has
such a beautifully clean expression profile.
But there aren't many targets that have that same clean expression
profile. Most targets are also expressed in
the tissue of origin for the tumor.
And so what happens when we want to develop a molecule where the expression
profile doesn't look quite so clean?
And STIP1 is a target that has been known for some time and is
expressed in prostate cancer.
And you can see here the expression profile compared to DLL3.
You've got quite a bit more expression, this is RNA data, in the
normal tissues. Looks quite different from
DLL3. Great expression in prostate tumors.
Again, STIP1 is expressed in almost all prostate
tumors.
And so to generate a molecule with this type of target
expression data, we collaborated with our colleagues from
Xencor to generate the molecule shown on the right-hand side of
the slide.
This molecule is now known as zalyuritamic.
It has two binding domains to STIP1.
And together, it relies on avidity to drive the activity
in cells. It has a different CD3 binder in this
case. It's not quite so potent. And it also has
a silent FC domain added to prolong the half-life in the
clinic.
What we found by taking this dual targeting,
avidity-based approach was that we could dial in and
out the amount of activity. And I don't have time to go
into the data today, but what we found was that the dual
binding or the bivalent binding allowed us to
target cells that express more than 10,000 receptors per
cell. And it turns out that tumor cells
usually express more than 10,000 receptors per cell, whereas
normal tissue does not.
And so, again, very compelling preclinical data from
zalyuritamic. You can see in the subcutaneous model,
very low doses result in great activity in this mouse
model. And also in a bone metastasis model,
here we're measuring tumor bioluminescence within the bone.
And again, zalyuritamic had great activity here.
It was well-tolerated in non-clinical safety studies
and gave us conviction that we should move this molecule into clinical testing
too.
The waterfall plot for zalyuritamic is shown here.
This was a dose escalation Phase 1 study.
And what you're looking at is the change in PSA.
The patients that reach a reduction of 50% PSA
are marked by the black line, and the patients that receive a PSA
90 or a 90% reduction are marked by the blue
line at the bottom.
And so again, very encouraging data in this Phase 1 study.
And zalyuritamic is now in Phase 3 trials for
patients with castrate-resistant prostate cancer.
So again, there aren't many targets that have that
nice clean expression profile.
And so we've been looking for ways that we might improve therapeutic window
and move into additional tumor indications.
And one approach that we think holds great promise is what we
refer to as dual targetingThis is a
logic-gated approach very similar to the logic
gates that you hear about in the computing world.
And how it works, you need the molecule to bind to
two targets on a tumor cell. In the example I'm going to tell
you about, those two targets are CDH3 and
mesothelin.
And
CDH3 and mesothelin are expressed on normal
cells,
but they're never or very rarely expressed on the same
normal cells together.
And so when the molecule only binds to one of the receptors, it has very
little activity, and when it binds to both receptors,
it has very good cytotoxic activity.
The synapse swarms, and the cancer cells die.
The preclinical data for 305 are shown here.
This is the expression profile that I just mentioned.
You can see two examples, pancreatic cancer and colorectal
cancer express very high levels of both targets.
But the blue dots represent the normal tissue expression.
And you can see that some tissues do actually express both
CDH3 and mesothelin.
But it turns out that that expression is not within the same
cells.
So CDH3 is usually expressed on cells of
epithelial origin, and mesothelin is not
expressed on cells of
epithelial origin, giving us conviction that if we could
derive a therapeutic that only worked when it bound both
receptors, we would improve the therapeutic window.
The structure of the molecule AMG 305 is shown on the
right-hand side of the slide.
It binds to CDH3 and mesothelin
on separate arms.
And importantly, this molecule has two CD3
binding domains. And
altogether, this molecule, the avidity, and the dual
targeting results in very specific cell killing of
cells that express both targets.
That data is shown on this slide.
The green line shows cells that express both CDH3 and
mesothelin, and you can see very potent activity with
AMG 305 in a cell-based assay.
Cells that just express one receptor, so either
mesothelin or CDH3, have much less
activity with AMG 305, in line with the mechanism
I just told you about.
Again, we see very good activity in preclinical models.
This is a gastric cancer xenograft that expresses both
CDH3 and mesothelin, and at very low doses, we see
good activity in the mouse models.
Importantly, AMG 305 was extremely
well-tolerated in our safety studies.
So much so, it was tolerated at exposure levels that we think will
well exceed the human efficacious dose.
And the safety profile was
very different from the single-targeting T-cell engager
molecules. So a molecule targeting mesothelin
alone or CDH3 alone doesn't look anywhere near as good
in safety studies.
So of course, this gave us conviction that we should move AMG
305 into clinical studies.
This phase one study has recently completed.
The indications that we looked at were colorectal, pancreatic,
non-small cell, and some gynecological malignancies.
These was indications that we knew were going to express high levels of
both receptors. And we hope to be releasing this
data later this year.
So what I've told you about today are different engineering approaches
that have allowed us to develop molecules very specific to the
targets and the challenges that we've observed in solid
tumors.
You see the prototype, the blinatumomab molecule that doesn't
have the extended FC. By adding the extended FC,
we've now been able to deliver intermittent IV or
subcutaneous delivery.
By using the avidity approach or the two plus one binding, we've
improved therapeutic index, and we're very optimistic that
dual targeting will allow us to move into other indications.
So T-cell engagers are now a validated form of cancer
immunotherapy. We think these engineering
innovations are going to allow us to expand other molecules
into new indications and patient populations.
I'd like to thank the patients, the families, and the caregivers who have
participated in these clinical studies.
I've been at Amgen a long time, and I've had the distinct pleasure
of meeting some of the patients that have benefited from these
therapies.
I can tell you as a scientist, there is no greater reward
than meeting a patient that has benefited from such serious
diseases.
And I want to thank all of you at the meeting here this year for the
work you do to bring forward new and exciting innovative
therapies to patients with such serious disease.
I also need to thank all of my colleagues, past and
former, from Amgen. Many people have contributed to
the programs I've talked to you about today. Thank you very much.
Thank you very much, Dr. Coxon. Really amazing talk, and thank you for
sharing those data with us. Very exciting technologies coming
through.
So now it's my pleasure to invite Professor John
Hannan, who's a consultant medical oncologist and director of the Center
for Cell Therapy at the Netherlands Cancer Institute,
and he will be talking to us on TIL therapy of solid cancers,
T cell features, and clinical activity. John, thank you.
Thank you very much, Katie, for the kind introduction, and thank you,
ACR, for allowing me to stand here on this last-day
plenary session.
Today, I would like to give you an update on where we stand with TIL
for solid cancer, although I will be mostly talking about
melanoma. And in the second part of my talk, I will show you some insights
and correlates that we find in the product
with clinical outcome.
During my presentation, I will show you
pictures and names of the people who were instrumental for the data
that I will be presenting. Most of the work is unpublished.
So here are my disclosures, and none of them are relevant for today's
presentation.
So when you think about TIL therapy, what is required
first is a surgical resection of a metastatic
lesion.
And then that material is enzymatically digested
or fragmented, and then those fragments or cell
suspensions are cultured in the presence of very high
concentrations of interleukin-2, up to 6,000 units per
milliliter. And upon initial TIL growth,
the cells are then further very aspecifically expanded in the
presence of soluble CD3 antibody,
irradiated allogeneic feeder cells, and again, high doses of
interleukin-2 to really amount to a product which consists
solely of CD3 positive cells in the billions.
And meanwhile, the patient is admitted to the hospital
to receive lymph depleting
chemotherapy consisting of cyclophosphamide and fludarabine, quite high
doses, followed by then
TIL infusion, and after TIL infusion, a couple of doses
of high-dose interleukin-2.
Around 2012, we knew that coming from phase one and phase
two studies in multiple institutions, that very consistently
TIL showed clinical efficacy in patients with metastatic
melanoma, and it was, of course, at the time that also checkpoint inhibition became
available.
So at that time, we had an important question to answer.
Would it be possible to estimate a true value of TIL
therapy by comparing it head-to-head with the standard of care?
And at the time, there was not so much interest
by pharma for TIL. Of course, that changed over time.
And therefore, we thought that a randomized control trial should be done in an
academic setting. And if that trial would be positive, would
TIL become available as a new standard of care treatment?
So I teamed up with Inge Riis-Faine
from Copenhagen in Denmark, who was also running trials
with TIL in patients with melanoma, and together we
designed a randomized controlled phase three trial.
This was 2014, and at that time, there was already
very interesting data, very promising data from nivolumab and pembrolizumab as
first-line treatment for patients with metastatic melanoma.
So we allowed one prior line of treatment in the study.
And in fact, almost 90% of the patients treated in
this randomized controlled phase three trial had progressed on prior
anti-PD-1 treatment. So 168 patients were
randomized to receive either TIL, exactly the way I described to you
before, or as a standard of care, ipilimumab at a
dose of three milligrams per kilogram every three weeks for a maximum of
four doses. And then those patients would be followed.
The primary endpoint of the study was progression-free survival according to RECIST
1.1 in the intention-to-treat population.
We showed that the primary endpoint was met with a
clear improvement in progression-free survival for patients
treated with TIL compared to ipilimumab.
And this was statistically significant but also highly clinically relevant.
Also, a secondary endpoint, best objective response rate, was much better for
patients treated with TIL, 49%
overall response rate and 20% of these patients having a complete response.
In terms of safety,
this was mostly coming from the lymph depleting
chemotherapy and the high-dose interleukin-2 doses, and that is
quite manageable in experienced hands.
So what is the current status of TIL therapy for melanoma?
First, of course, we have the commercial
AMTAGV, coming from Iovence, life
Leucel, a commercial FDA accelerated approved,
cryopreserved autologous and modified TIL product for the treatment of patients
with metastatic melanoma
following a progressive disease on
all lines of standard treatment.
And then we have DM-001, a non-commercial fresh
autologous and modified TIL product that came from our randomized controlled phase
three trial, which is
currentlyUnder hospital exemption being
reimbursed in the Netherlands and Denmark for the treatment of a resectable
cutaneous stage three and four melanoma patients having progressed
on anti-PD-1 based therapies. And we use the data
for a marketing authorization application, and it's currently under review by
EMA. This is important because in the US, of course, lifileucel
is approved, and there are negotiations ongoing in other countries for
regulatory approval in the UK and Switzerland and Canada, I guess, and
Australia, but not in mainland Europe because
the company withdrew the marketing authorization application
last year.
Luckily, there's a lot of interest now, more interest now of pharma
in TIL, and we do see that there is new developments
coming either from gene modified TIL also outside of
melanoma in other indications.
In the meanwhile,
we treated over 130 patients in the real world,
as of January
2023.
So for 100 patients, we had enough follow-up of more than
10 months, and of these 100 patients, 91
received TIL treatment. So all underwent mastectomy, but only
91 patients were really treated and therefore were evaluable for
response. And what you can see is that there are now two cohorts of
patients, a cohort of patients
that progress on anti-PD-1 alone, 47 patients, and 40
patients had received prior ipilimumab plus nivolumab.
That is a population that we never treated in the clinical
trial.
When you look at the baseline characteristics, there's not a huge difference
between these two cohorts, and especially also not if you compare it
to the patients treated in the randomized controlled
phase three trial. Although the anti-PD-1 pretreated patients had
received anti-PD-1 as an adjuvant treatment, and for the
ipilimumab pretreated patients, they had received ipilimumab as first
line or second line, and also in this population, there were more patients with an
elevated LDH,
so a poorer patient population.
When you look at treatment characteristics, there was not a difference between
these two groups and not where we derived
the TIL from,
also not in the number of
infused cells or the doses of interleukin-2 the patient received
following an infusion.
If you compare the progression-free survival of this real world
cohort with the progression-free survival we saw in the phase three
trial, and for the latter, we had to recalculate the PFS from the day
of TIL infusion and not of randomization, which of course is normally done,
then you can see that the PFS is quite similar between these two.
Importantly, follow-up time is much shorter for the
real world data. In the real world cohorts, you see that the best objective
response rate for anti-PD-1 pretreated patients was 45%, very
similar to what we'd seen in the randomized control phase three trial,
but it was clearly somewhat lower for the ipilimumab plus nivolumab treated
patients, 30%.
If you break down then PFS and OS per prior line of treatment in
the real world setting, you can see that patients pretreated with
anti-PD-1 do better in PFS and OS compared to
patients pretreated with ipilimumab plus nivolumab.
That's the green curve here.
But if you look at the overall survival of patients responding to TIL or
progressing on and not responding to TIL, there's clearly a big
benefit for those patients that respond.
So TIL therapy in the real world, anti-PD-1 refractory patients, so
very similar outcomes to clinical trial patients.
But if you
were treated priorly with ipilimumab, nivolumab, the results seem to be
what lower,
in terms of best objective response rate and also shorter survival, although
still these patients benefit even in long term.
If you compare TIL therapy to a gene
modified product, which is highly defined, either a CAR
T-cell or a T-cell receptor T-cell,
and TIL is completely different. Because every time we infuse the
cells, we don't know what these cells recognize and what the number
of cells are that are tumor reactive.
We know, of course, that there is an endogenous intratumoral T-cell receptor
repertoire that should be able to recognize
the tumor cells, but we have no idea what the composition is at the time
that we infuse these cells.
So the question has been in the field, which TIL really matter for
response?
Could we use T-cell receptor as a metric for potential
activity of a TIL product? In order to investigate this,
we set up a couple of technologies.
First, we build a large autologous antigen library.
We took tumor cells and healthy cells from the patient, performed whole exome
sequencing and RNA sequencing to allow variant calling.
And from every non-synonymous mutation, we generated a single minigene.
At the same time, from the B cells from the patient, we
immortalized these by transduction with Bcl-6 and
Bcl-XL and used these as a continuous source of
antigen-presenting cells. We then
expressed this library of minigenes in these
B cells.
That was the large antigen library that we used then for screening.
We added also a lot of other antigens, tumor-associated antigens, either
coming from the cancer testes antigens or additional shared antigens that we
know can be recognized by T-cells, some model antigens, and a large number of
viral antigens as well.
Second step was to select a number of TCRs from the TIL.
So we performed single-cell RNA sequencing and T-cell receptor sequencing
of the digest where the TIL were grown from, and also bulk
TCR sequencing from the infusion product, and we looked at the
TCRs shared between these two.Now, this can amount to
thousands of different
TCRs, and if you want to then
investigate
thousands of different TCRs
together with thousands of different antigens in the library, that
becomes an enormous amount of work, which is unfeasible.
Therefore, we had to select a number of TCRs.
So we selected 100 TCRs, and we made use of predicted
tumor activity. And that you can use, let's say,
a transcriptional signature for that, that it's publicly
available. In this case, we used the one Frank Lowrey,
who published that in "Science"
two years ago. And we added also 10% of the most abundant
clones in the infusion product. And we cloned these TCRs and put these
in healthy donor T cells.
We had of these patients that we treated in the clinical trial, six
patients that had as best response progressive disease, and
also seven patients that had a complete response
following
TIL. And we'll show you the results of two patients, starting with 102,
and later also patient 19.
So what you do then is to culture the T cell receptor
expressing healthy donor T cells, together with the
large B cell library and with autologous B cells.
And if there was a T cell receptor in there that can recognize one of these B cell
expressing antigens, this B cell will be deleted and
destroyed by the T cells. And
you can measure that by performing deep sequencing of genomic
DNA, and you can express that then in these MA plots,
where you see that the ones that are depleted drop out of this cloud of
B cells antigens there.
So how does it look like in the real world?
Here's a dropout screen of TCRs that were very low in
new antigens
TCR signature. And you can see a couple of dropouts, see these blue
dots at the bottom here. And if you look
what these antigens are that are being recognized, these are all coming from viral
antigens, so in this case, EBV.
If you do the same for the same patients, but now select TCRs that were
just
coming from neoantigen TCR signature high TIL, again,
we found a couple of dropouts, and all of these are new antigens, and they could be
validated separately. And as you can see, the T cell receptors only
recognized the mutant variant, but not the wild type variant.
Now, going to patient 19,
we also had a possibility to look at CD4
T cells. So again, here to the
bottom, you see CD4 T cells with low new TCR signature.
We didn't find any dropouts. But if you do that for the high new
antigens TCR signature
or the most abundant
T cells, TCRs in the TIL product, we found here
one antigen, LH2, and one new antigen for the CD4 T cells.
And for the CD8,
again for the low new TCR signature,
we found again viral antigens and MART-1.
But for the T cells with the high new antigen TCR signature, we found
again a cancer tested antigen and
a new antigen, and in the most abundant one,
also T cells that were specific for GP-100.
When you do this for the whole population, and
unfortunately we have done this now for 10 of the 13 patients, you start seeing
a difference between patients that had a complete response and
patients that had a progressive disease, both for the CD4 and the CD8
T cells. Although you find
also in the patients that progressed until
all three categories back, but the abundance of antigens that are being
recognized seem to be higher for the patients that have a
response.
So using dropout screens, we started to deconvolute the TIL infusion
product, and we find in responding patients an abundance of
TEA and new antigens,
both in the CD4 and the CD8 compartment.
But currently, we don't know which of these antigens is really important for the
response that we see in these patients, how many TCRs we find per antigen,
and which of these T cells in fact expand in vivo
following TIL infusion and lead to tumor cell killing.
And of course, we want to investigate the relation between tumor activity and
clinical response to TIL. So we asked another question: Can we predict clinical
outcome based on the cell product that we manufactured?
So we reasoned that CD8 phenotype could play a large
role in clinical response, and in order to capture cellular
heterogeneity
and enable phenotype response associations, we undertook deep
sequencing
of CD8 TIL from
patients' tumor digest and paired
infusion product from seven complete responders and six
non-responders. So these were the same patients as I mentioned before.
So we performed single cell RNA sequencing, TCR sequencing, and
CITE-seq of the original product, and
bulk TCR sequencing of the
TIL infusion product.
And to integrate the CD8 T cells across patients, we
applied a single-cell variational inference model,
which revealed clear partitioning of transcriptionally distinct
gene expression
programs.
And when you look at these programs, you can see that this
reveals a separation of previously defined T
cell subset like maids and effect memory,
naive, dysfunctional, TEMRA. But additionally,
our TILnap enabled separation of resident here,
dysfunctional
cells from
terminally dysfunctional cells,
and also distinct tumor reactive origins, precursor
dysfunctional cells as well.So it's a more granular
gene expression map than we had seen before.
So we next asked the question whether predicted tumor reactivity
and CD8 TIL state composition can stratify patients
independently of clinical outcome.
And we used, again, for this, the neoantigen TCR signature that I
mentioned to you before and established a single-cell
transcriptional signature that predicts,
T cell reactivity. So this is the same one that we used
before coming from Frank Lowery's work to identify
functionally relevant
CD8 TILS, and we observed a continuous gradient, as
you can see here,
of predicted tumor activity across the CD8 TIL
map,
with high reactivity coinciding here with these
dysfunctional states.
Then we categorized
for every individual
T cell in the
product,
the reactivity at the cell level. So this characterization
revealed that in these progressive patients,
there are two patients that have a high abundance of
T cells that are very low in tumor reactivity.
Maybe not so surprising that these patients may not respond to TIL
therapy. But we also see, and this is a little bit unexpected,
four patients here that also didn't respond, although they have
quite a high abundance of cells with very high tumor reactivity, which is,
in fact, equivalent to what we've seen in responders patients.
So apparently, this
doesn't distinguish responders from non-responders.
We call these
four patients non-responder high patients and the others non-responder low
patients.
And in order to directly link
the CD8 T cell states to clonal expansion during TIL
production, we next mapped the expanded TCR
clonotypes in the infusion product back to their
originating transcriptional states in the tumor digest.
And this enabled us to determine whether expanded clones
preferentially
originated from tumor-reactive CD8 TIL states.
And what you do see in responders, that the majority of the
expanded clones are derived from tumor-reactive
CD8 states, here to the right, whereas in both
non-responder high and non-responder low
patients, a substantial fraction of expanded clonotypes
originated from tumor-reactive bystander states.
So we tried to define the phenotypic features distinguishing
tumor-reactive cells in responders from these non-responding
counterparts in these non-responding high patients.
And for this,
we did a gene set enrichment analysis,
and that showed that in the tumor-reactive cells from
responders, there was enrichment for IL-2/STAT5 signaling
and TNF alpha signaling, proliferation, and stemness-associated programs that
we did not find in the non-responder high patients.
And especially the IL-2 pathway activity was interesting.
As I mentioned to you in the beginning, we grow these cells in high doses of
interleukin 2, and of course, the
CD25 is an important
component of the high-affinity IL-2 receptor, which drives
proliferation. So we use
CyTOF to
stain for CD25 expression. And what we did see
is that in the responding patients, we found much more
cells and higher expression of CD25 compared to these
non-responding high patients.
And when you look back at the product that we infuse and look at the
T cell receptor clone size, you can see that most of these clones in the responding
patients were derived from these CD25-expressing
cells, which did not occur
in the
non-responding high patients. So
collectively, these data identify CD25 positive
tumor-reactive Goldilock states that couples tumor recognition with
IL-2 responsiveness and expansion
capacity. Absence of this state is an explanation
for impaired expansion of tumor-reactive T cells during TIL
production.
Lastly, would like to show across the three
patient cohorts, the blood TCR. So we looked in the blood
after TIL infusion, what happened to the
TCRs that we
infused.
And we matched these to the digest TCRs, here shown to the
left. And in blue here are the non-reactive,
and in orange here are the reactive ones.
And results demonstrate, and when you look here at these tumor-reactive
cells, that there's a higher fraction of predicted
tumor-reactive clones
in the blood of responders compared to these non-responder
cohorts. But tumor-reactive
cells here seem to decrease over time
at week 12, and we assume that this has something to do with the
fact that these patients respond clinically.
So using single-cell RNA sequencing, T cell receptor sequencing, and
CyTOF sequencing analysis of tumor digest used to manufacture
a TIL product, non-responders to TIL therapy either lacked
tumor-reactive TIL or tumor-reactive TIL were highly
dysfunctional. And I didn't show you, but they are very high
in EMS,
which precluded expansion in the drug product.Responder
patients displayed tumor-reactive TIL, we call them Goldilocks cells,
that were high in CD25 expression and had a separate
transcriptional profile, which expanded into the drug product.
In responder patients, T cells appear to expand in circulation
following TIL infusion. In non-responders, expanding cells are mostly
bystander T cells.
So in conclusion,
TIL therapy is a highly effective treatment, especially for
patients with immune checkpoint blockade-refractory
metastatic melanoma.
TIL therapy, therefore, should become a standard of care everywhere in the
world for patients with metastatic melanoma in this
setting.
TIL are often reactive to tumor-associated antigens and
neoantigens. More tumor antigens recognized by TIL can be found in
responders compared to non-responders.
TIL from other cancers, like endometrial cancer and penile cancer,
with a much lower tumor mutational burden, can also be
tumor-associated antigen or neoantigen reactive.
And here you see some of the work we did in other cancer types
using the dropout screens. And what you do see is, again, you find these
TAA and neoantigen-specific populations, but you also see that there
are many more of these bystander cells recognizing viral
antigens. And in the penile cancer, these were all HPV-negative
patients, so that this was not based on HPV recognition.
So it may be more complicated to grow TIL from other indications.
Lastly, T cell features within tumor digests are predictive of clinical
outcome, and this knowledge should be utilized to improve
next-generation TIL therapies.
With that, I've come to the end of my presentation, and I would of course like to
thank the patients and the families that participated in the trials that we did,
but also the many people involved in the clinic, pharmacy, and our
research
division at NKI, our collaborators in Denmark, and the
many funding bodies that helped us perform this work.
With that, I would like to thank you very much for your attention.
Thank you very much, Dr. Hannon. Really exciting data and beautiful
presentation.
So I would just like to just spend the last minute or so just
wrapping up and really thanking you all for being
here. I think that if there's one
takeaway, it's that we are not really choosing
amongst drugs now. We are deciding and choosing between
platforms, and each of them come with their own
benefits and limitations.
You heard today why theranostics and radioligand
therapy are moving so quickly, and they
connect diagnosis and treatment in a way that we can
measure.
And the opportunity now is to push beyond the cancers where the
playbook is already being written to novel treatments
and novel indications,
with better targets, better dosimetry, and smarter
combinations, as so elegantly presented by Dr. Pomper.
ADCs have also come a very long way. You heard from Dr.
Colombo really the exciting innovation, the novel targets,
the science around linkers, and
the exciting pipeline that is coming our way.
And now the question is going to be how to pick the right
patients and what will be the right sequence of therapy.
You heard on the
innovation
around T-cell engagers and the
biology around also targeting
solid tumors. And of course, with targeting of solid tumors,
as elegantly presented by Dr. Coxon, we need to think about
safety,
durability, and resistance, and engineering will allow us
to get there. And finally, from Dr.
Hannon,
a real reminder that cell therapies can
have a huge impact in solid tumors.
You
saw those incredible clinical responses that were
observed. And so with better functional studies and perhaps
with the addition of genetic modifications, we can make those cells
even more potent for our patients with solid cancers.
So with that, I would like to once again thank our speakers for their
outstanding presentations, and thank you for your participation,
and safe travels home, everyone. Thank you.